ciao ragazzi son finite le feste e credo
che sia arrivato il momento di mangiare
in maniera sana di mangiare in maniera
equilibrata e di sfruttare tutto quello
che abbiamo ingerito dal agosto tratte
che semmai e new talent i catalani
queste vacanze sono state abbastanza
toste per tutti quanti noi
io ho preso credo 4 kg tutto ripreso 76
esploso il big bang minuto dopo un
pranzo di natale 506 la rappresentazione
di un miracolo della vita c'è l'essenza
gratuita e per iniziare quest'anno ho
pensato di buttarmi a cucinare con
microonde in modo a creare qualcosa di
veloce e non ho trovato qualcosa di
leggero quindi faremo delle patatine
fritte e scopriremo anche l'udinese il
ketchup in pochissimo tempo
partiamo subito con il procedimento
possa avere un si scelse jacques fesch
in contemporanea si dice perfetto dopo c
che sentirete sono quelle dei miei
familiari abbiamo chef rico chef mario e
chef ottavio grazie sfruttarlo per
essere venuta qui con noi abbiamo
bisogno di una rata dell'olio del sale
basta questo a cameri molto sia facile
insomma per prima cosa parliamo la
patata e scialpi natola
se si possa fare una cosa fare di quella
visita a termine si no
sono due è stata chiesta facciamo questa
si prenderà un piatto e una candelina
che serve per affettare sottile sottile
le cose e prendere le dita perché noi le
gite all'estero bisogna fare è portare
il nome di tali 8 rumore strano
direi limitate allora andiamo scusa ho
sbagliato
prendiamo le chips a rotolo di chips e
mettiamole in un sì va beh potete farlo
prima capito ho preso questo non
sbagliato con un pochino di olio di semi
perché non trovate quello lì d'oliva
mettiamo sciacca dakar comunque molto
meglio farla a casa
ok microonde per una scommessa con la
vita a questo punto arriva difficile
prendere il piatto di vetro del
microonde
ma che nessuno lava mai prendete della
carta da forno e iniziato un certo che
sia perfettamente dentro le forbicine
cucina di mia strada so queste qui
dell'albero azzurro trasferta a casa
[Musica]
prendiamo quindi adesso le nostre chips
per disponiamo in uno strato ma allora
sa quello che fa e ora una bella proprio
che tu dici a queste quella del mancio
comitato felicità ma nessuna di queste
restando gioia la cascina abitata
successo successo
molto bassa a 5 milioni come funziona
male ma date si aspetta patate stream
betti flash price di 44
[Musica]
mi dicevo minuti su delle ombre può
portare di parlare ma devo mettercela
ora facciamo un al trasferimento prima
di assaggiarle numero limitato pur
rimetterci il sale quindi a questa botta
li mettiamo un po per sé una scelta olio
dello chef per fare fa male sì è vero sì
è vero il fatto è che sono molto sottili
queste molto sottili quindi vengono
delle carezze quest anno sono cir che si
sono carezze di patata sembrare anche il
culo di un porno a questo punto po di
sale chaka chaka rochus usa ma il sale
non si mette così male si bloccano
elezioni ripartiamo subito adesso con le
salse facciamo la prima ricarica mentre
dovrebbe essere più fabi
[Musica]
meglio non si potrebbe dire lavater per
la maglia dice avevo bisogno di un
meeting un uovo oli di semi aceto io ho
preso quello di mele per non lontano la
certo quello che devo avere perso sale
un libro sì non lo so quindi credo che
andrò occhio spostiamoci da quest altro
lato prenderò l'uomo preso dipendere ok
un pizzico di sale a un pochino d'aceto
sasha xaxa dovremo andare a filo con
l'olio
[Musica]
ecco o meglio l'aspetto scenate la
melitese cambia cosa interessa vuol dire
che maionese ok chef mario con le linee
1 a latina perfetto fidanzia immagina
con questo per me ma l'aspetto non è
male che può sembrare poi arriviamo fai
questo calcio affitto in due minuti a
casa serviranno del concentrato di
pomodoro dello sciroppo d'acero corre dc
con la follia
partiamo subito con procedimento che in
realtà è molto semplice ma prendete un
vincere e una forchetta ma che ci
dobbiamo mangiare questo era un po
concentrando tanto il concentrato di
pomodoro e le dosi non le sono un
pochino di sciroppo d'acero basta ho
esagerato
non lo so aceto di mele la scusa nel
caso di cerci perché questo è un fashion
sperimentale di luce
no non c'è traccia no no no non c'è e
origano come non fare qualcosa di veloce
per le vecchie fi alla sun e demoni stia
per terra
[Musica]
manca che lo sciroppo d'acero
di sicuro americano sta creando siti
capisco perché c'è un bel un barile di
scusate le scuse accettate
intanto preparo se siamo privati di
questa ricetta che se qui erano le mie
patatine fritte in quattro minuti con
cacia in due minuti e maionese in un
minuto praticamente uno snack in meno di
[Risate]
farvi sapere con delle foto con delle
stories pagatemi su instagram dove gli
pare se proverete questa ricetta e
soprattutto fatemi sapere come vi è
venuta naturalmente in un appuntamento
alla prossima domenica con un altra
punta di sentire ma volete provare
secondo business roberti la maionese si
riproverà oppure la maionese avesse la
mano di nesima la prova prima la
maionese è bella da vedere atti per
questo mi fai arrabbiare poi farà quel
sapore di asfalto demoni bile lega cos'è
terribile quindi quella che se
riprendendo vi serve una bella tosta
festa c'è mai
murray ti aspetto meno bella della
maggioranza
madonna non pensate che sia veramente
disgustoso questa del catch up in sé
questa del ketchup cacchio tendente
stata la puglia sta strana strana
anch'io ho messo soltanto stava dentro
però solo quello che lascia solo questo
ho messo il resto peso caricato anche
questo a volte portano a niente ma da
quella the spuntino veramente sentito
crash accusa certo che ciò cosa è buona
diciamo esperimento di questi
classifichiamo i voti però mi guarda che
bella perda vedere diciamo infatti che
buonissima tanto sociali aspetto sette e
mezzo sapore aspetto le 22
vabbè c'è un gioco di peggio questo è
meglio di sé non è tutto tranne che
maionese questo propria gente 56 e mezzo
sette meno tratto meno le patate e che
lei essendo meno 7 più tonini del bene 7
più anche perché è comunque c'erano
basse aspettative su queste parole
parate 7 più questo è da dimenticare
monterà il video
sicuri